[Musique]
ouais je pense que ça vole on voit un
hameau merci d'être chez nous plaisait
mou et là derrière toi la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus c'était au repos les
ados des ça fait un ace de boudin donc
ça fait 8 10 mois en commun aller on
s'entend en fait ce qui fait un as et
marca qu'on s'est rencontrés ouais bah
faut comme si longtemps au dauphin à
l'hôtel dauphin en faire don à 6,20 peux
te le revaudra j'en ai fait lire tout
moutapha ouais c'est que certaines
machines à 11 varois noir ça sera pareil
ça sera jamais pareil ouais ouais vous
tournez les autres y maintenant il
m'avait demandé de loin
j'en veux encore la belle maison qui
tarit pas voulu bt banon mais je pense
qu'au niveau local filas laisserait pour
tous et non c'est ça la faction avec
jesse l'autre fois parce que honda fit
lire tom cruise des images nt1
il nous faut revenir en finale contre
les deux autres coupe metton est le fils
y retourne parce que yopougon un peu le
temps vécu ce qu'on a vécu voir puis
mettons qu'un lp est partie daudet c'est
là c'est leur unique tough c'est et
arras c'était difficile mais c'est là
que c'est devenu vraiment un autre game
menottes à faire complètement puis c'est
ce que le monde qui retourne pu me tonti
je pense à catherine l'ami dany ce
qu'ils veulent - secte et elle n'a pas
une mauvaise feedback de leur expérience
parce qu'elle ne sait comment à la
naissance un peu le temps de vivre c'est
dans maison défis qu un tel bordel cinq
en lice mais c'est ça mais les finales
et je pense pas qu'elles seraient pas
retournés motown même n'avons pas gagné
ce serait pourtant honda ce constat
disons c'est à dire justement
va parler là bob thorton là dessus car
mais c'est pas aussi facilement passé
qui mène sa maison puis piquez le est ce
que est ce que même avec tout ce que tu
as eue après pleuve pas du prix
nécessairement c'est sûr qu'un chalet à
tremblant c'est utile mais mais est ce
que tout ce qui déboulait d'être ce
jeune âge in beaucoup de guigues on voit
les gros bémol on y comptera évidemment
compte instagram est ce que ça ça vaut
la peine d'avoir fait toutes mes excuses
à exclure le prix ben parce que le
feeling se seraient rendus là quand même
ou peut-être mais vraiment plus de temps
si j'ai des ressources que j'aurais pas
à cause de la visibilité que le monde
veulent très moi parce qu'on est déjà un
public
maintenant on a un public maintenant on
a une visibilité qu'on n'avait pas bien
on l'avait mais vraiment pas aussi
intense le viseur des décaissements des
millions de vues le sait et ans le
domaine au québec ces foules mais oui
mais je suis extrêmement reconnaissant
par rapport à ça mais je te dirais que
non je pense pas que j'aurais pu tout ce
ça aurait été différent mais sa réponse
je sais pas si j'aime ce les réseaux
sociaux je trouve ça difficile à
internet mcafee petit on est un petit
peu plus vieux que je sais pas si ces
seules ses suppôts nez là dedans j'ai
pas eu j'ai jamais comme couru après ça
jamais également mon but d'abord 140000
2010 des bons mots temps je faisais ma
musique que ça parce qu'elles m'ont
écouté je m'en fous c'est soit qu'il y
ait des avantages
genre justement tiers à travers les
réseaux sociaux si je peux plus parler
de la musique
moi tout ce que je fais dans le fond ce
plus pour la musique pour peut-être
aussi peut-être la télé j'aimerais ça
être la télémédecine une chose à fois
laissé beaucoup de travail pour mettre
une émission qui travaille là-dessus
sujet découvrir de ça prend c'est un
long long long processus et avant
d'arriver qu'une émission puis d'abord
cogné à la porte des diffusions pour
acid2 réussira à part sa télé justement
si c'est bon tu écoutes tu vois ce que
tu imagines n'était pas d'émission
mettront dessus un conseil quant à moi
je conseille peut pas parler c'est un
super beau projet mettons que mettons
que ça se passe au québec au québec fax
et collages et ses sages et à ces jeux
un peu justement ouvrir un peu les yeux
des québécois au monde extérieur c'est
peut-être qu est ce que je pense que
c'est une chose qui manque sérieusement
d'armes qui est un programme du
gouvernement
des subventions pour que les gens
voyagent c'est parce que c'est quelque
chose qui manque aux québécois je pense
de voyager parce que de voir autre chose
déclare ici bon c'est bon tu dis ça
parce que je me rappelle en étant à
l'hôtel dauphin qu'ils aient jamais
jamais pris l'avion pour sortir du pays
puis là on s'en allait pour ben ali
après ce tour japon après 7 est allé à
singapour semaine je le ferais n'importe
quoi pour sac à patates je leur ai
refait mais encore une fois même comme
la première dans le fond que ma première
fois comme la première fois je suis allé
vraiment plus pour les voyages très
honnêtement je pense que tous s'y plier
pour l'expérience que c'était plus pour
une recherche pour voir comment ça se
passe
toute petite elle use bonne idée parce
que c'est tellement sympa donné grand
chose mais bah si c'est grande haya
basque et bath et le repas de famille au
final de vos pieds c'est un projet
maîtrise et pim
ouais moi je t'aime moi je quittais on
se connaît depuis longtemps et on se
connaissait à 20 pi
je connaissais le péage qui s'en allait
au deck est excité métier seulement
savent pas c'est que c'est un vrai
projet vraiment raconter très pauvre de
maîtrise pour dire je m'envole eur puis
à la face et puis c'est pas l'unique
raison je pense pour laquelle l'italie
non ça faisait partie des raisons je
disais allez pour vrai et et pour le fun
projet liant l'expérience music mais en
même temps il y avait des clans
documenté puis de faire des cours d un
projet je pense que ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi je fais ma l'article dans le
devoir qui paraît d'être seul était mal
reçus ou mal perçu je pense qu'il est
trop proche des reçus ouais quand même
ça a été bien reçu par les gens qui
lisent le devoir mais ça a été repris
tout crush par des webzines l'article
niveau est super bon article dans le
vent est excellente a été repris
vraiment pas céder déclic bates rabelais
a essayé de jouer un tour
ils m'ont donc comme commencé à dire ah
mais c'est sûr c'est facile de dire que
ce soit les personnes faut que tu as
perdu 2,6 facile de l'arrêter style puis
mais si ça mais dans tous les cas
effectivement suivre j'y allais quand
même pour l'expérience
mais oui on en a vécu exact j'envie
encore grâce à ce succès serait jamais
vécu facture comme juste la sortie après
aude et le monde on parlait beaucoup le
témoin à la barre jamais écouté au décès
je pense que vous aussi
mais si j'avais jamais écouté ce que je
savais pas trop trop dans quoi je
m'embarquais je savais qu'avec ce voyage
savait qu'ils avaient des genres de jeux
d'amour d'amour et le savez il y avait
cet environnement lemay jeu mais je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça soit ou si
gros un certain jamais jamais jamais
jamais je pense que personne si la
tendance du texte ça allait être plus
gros que les autres années à cause des
mêmes qu'à l'émission astarté les
premières siemens était patent accès au
pis allait relever mais c'est comme
vraiment à face à fait bouclé cette
sortie des bleus qui vaut chiffon comme
explosé ouais moi je me suis caché sa
sortie jeter des jeux je paniquais des
jeux pour smartphones utilisant que
c'était quand j'ai reçu ce que j'ai vu
je me rappelle on s'était vus pital et
je file à pau le progrès des crises
anxiété jamais fait de ma vie c'était
trop c'est trop pour moi saga men sort
d'un bar le monde et reçoivent comme si
ces joj pas si j'ai pas trouvé leur
mission qui j'étais mais pourquoi je
vois autant de même si de l'amour même
si de la reine peu importe ce que c'est
c'est trop c'est quelque chose sentiment
vers toi c'est trop d'attention be c'est
moi je pensais que j'allais aimer ce
avoir l'attention c'est comme un asticot
le cema visibilité ça a marché de la
musique ça va aller mais quand je lis
les tournées du groupe b que j'adorais
c'était mon élément si je t'assure
estate je faisais ma musique le monde
tripes et le monde connaissait les
paroles feeling incroyable
le 20 septembre on n'est plus en train
de composer
en fait on est finie on vient
d'enregistrer la dernière un tour à
québec
chez max cru et je pense que c'est un
cadeau de rimouski en fait qui habite à
québec maintenant puis lui bref lui ont
été enregistrées chez eux
c'est noté c'est une machine préfrontal
à québec on a fini de nouvelles tours on
le sait sauf hacker geohot robic de 2 gb
sais pas comment l'appeler progrès mais
nous on est plus dans la finition mais
on pourra revenir à tout ceci qui jamais
ce pour la phase de groupes et pour les
shows mais mais l'espèce d'attention
quand certaines est mort c'était plus je
trouvais que j'avais par rapport je
comprenais pas pourquoi le texan rick
tout un échange dax en dhr et qu'est-ce
que tu seul j'aurais viré foule s'était
beaucoup ton spitz et les bordures
facile mais intense télphone cm mais
tant que championne est bon le jeu de
loto j'ai fait ça pendant combien de
temps me fait ce jusqu'à moi j'étais
chez moi à travers ce jeu faisait la
tournée des groupes humains plus factice
mais je voudrais c'est comme un gros
cochon à chabot que maintenant la
commission des liqueurs
ouais après c'est le lendemain je
faisais un show à drummondville un vrai
c'est le surlendemain star tourne et que
ça aurait quelque part là une achetée
scrap tout le temps est capable j'étais
fatigué je faisais des crises etc ça
existe et ça d'épaulé crise inquiète
elle place à un pic des inconnus qui ont
gagné ce jeu est le personnes
connaissent à ce test est lourde
est ce que je regrette d'avoir fait
d'avoir fait la tournée après non un
look une main parce que je termine et il
le sait dans le portefeuille moi ça m'a
donné ça m'a aidé un peu
[Musique]
et
moi aussi j'ai jamais été payé
j'apprécie je tenais dans mes affaires
et d'un pompier
j'ai fait seulement de l'argent que les
shows des gros big ticket - nancy huff
ok mais moyennant soirée d un peu
évidemment
puis mes mails et il se sert comme je te
disais tantôt que j'arrivais tout dessus
et l'ont au début quand je sors type
tout ça coule pas si j'avais une coupe
de contreur dessinée ça j'allais d'un
groupe dont faisait d'argent quand même
ça allait bien je faisais de l'argent là
je fais juste des meetings des meetings
je préfère dans chaque fois les meetings
en même temps limité qui sont utiles
pour je sais pas toi comment tu vois tu
vois c'est comment tu suces jauge le
truc pour compte en ligne pour c'était
sûrement une idée en tête comme ça en
tête on livre des recettes encaissées
s'est placé dans le fonds s'était
approchée pour ce mais ça ça fait
longtemps réattu le ouais vraiment
vraiment s'est fait approcher pour ce 2
mois prod est peut-être un mois et demi
à prod et puis le c'est devenu
automatiquement la sphère qui allait
nous faire subsister à nouveau des
pierres la nouvelle vague c'est parce
que j'ai l'impression que du monde qui
vont peut-être de tomber un peu dans
l'oubli une faute voire une deuxième
vague
c'est ce que je veux pas je ne veux pas
parce que t'as fait ça vaut rien et le
match avec jesse fait clairement c'est
pas pour rien deux danseuses
sauf que je me disais tu sais j pas j'ai
pas fait ce pourquoi utiliser comme ce
que j'ai acquis représentations partout
des réseaux sociaux uniquement
d'autres pensent que c'est juste les
réseaux sociaux maintenant mais ça c'est
vraiment un bon outil à faire autre
chose à faire de la musique avec en
ligne ont proposé sur la barque et à
forlan là-dessus fait que ça a été
vraiment du travail long ça et si l'on
passe qu'il fallait faire un deadline
quand même
roche le fallait pour sa soeur dans le
temps qu'on le fait qu'ils aient moins
d'un an
ici pas dans le livre de recettes des
fois c'est deux à trois ans de
préparation
quand j'ai vu que vous l'aviez sortie et
voulons vous le saurez oasis en
septembre fixée ça a été vraiment projet
lankais en silence et puis ça ça fait
que ben ofas vont être dans toutes les
provisions au maxi métro dans toutes les
causes qu hollywood les pharmacies sont
aussi bleus justement bolivie c'est sans
parler du mouvement parce que c'est
encore mieux c'est l'impact que ça va
avoir ses yeux le fait que ces suspects
comme un projet qui m'a permis de ne pas
trop entrer dans un espèce de tourbillon
d'essayer de trouver quoi c'est quoi la
prochaine afin savons déjà que ce que
j'avais acquis la prochaine en force et
ce après ça quand ça sera fini on se
frôle donc on arrivera finances a sauvé
un petit peu l'espèce détour du chemin
je me fais passer à ce que parler avec
eux un or si françois lambert le dragon
cochon et c'était sympa ces pilules ce
que tu veux un en affaires c'est facturé
quand tu dors cesser de faire de
l'argent s'offre un service steam et on
sera tournée des bars ou très chaud tout
représenter tout le pays du 5 500
chevaux mille piastres payer du tout
c'est tout québec je passe passe qui me
donald tusk
pis c'est de la danse et qui s'écoule
mais ammann et sophie n'est pas plafonné
parce que tu peux pas être à deux places
trois places en même temps c'est trop
cher à une place pour ce que la musique
pour moi c'est d'amuser great plus
vendre
des albums 68 allemand on n'a pas fait
des milliers non mais on n'a pas des
millions mais on a fait avec sa fête
pour hermann mouche le matin de passe
l'argent ça c'est cool ce bain et et
c'est comme ça qu'on a investi pour le
long les pas mal à cercle parce que ce
que je faisais pas d'énormes icebergs
non mais sur les fêtes vous faites vous
sur des t-shirts et de la meute chemin
on en a fait au début quand j'avais
passé une enfance sans andric quitte
plus les gros becs finalement ça se
transforme en gentilhomme depuis que
c'est gentillet mais on a comme stanier
l'exclu de long les bennes trou de cul
son bord son émission à canal vie si on
n'a pas de
avec son 3 il ya une zone ces gros big
l'album démons en place ont fait web
série qu'on commence ici - salon de ta
rennes est celle qui justement c'est
tout et puis quand je parle au téléphone
c'est justement c c'est mon pote qui des
moves est en voie de l'airial
probablement notre seul qui m'appelait
puisque donc quelques subventions aux
quand même c'était eux les jeunes
volontaires
on est on ne te gratter ou ce qu'il
fallait que ni les portes de vos choix
ce que je peux avec les groupies qu'on
va faire assez d'argent pour les vidéo
clips non c'est clair ce long processus
sommes exactement si c'en est un
plusieurs rafales il ya aussi le chalet
dit que moi je travaille aussi la turbo
avec monsieur chalet on s'associe à
acheter la part alexandre pour que dans
le fond l'on puisse commencer à louer
mais c'est pas encore fait
enfin fini probablement mi octobre on
tient on se dispute un an nous a
finalement à 70 afin qu'ils arrivent
c'est des gros projets des gros projets
viennent des gros coup avec des gros
coups viennent des ultras heureux
d'avoir un chalet petit mais c'est
beaucoup de travail dit tu peux pas
l'argent commence à voir dans ta voix tu
passes à fessenheim tout le temps check
points mais en même temps mais vraiment
c'est vraiment beaucoup de choses autant
le vécu un peu en sortant comme se lance
dans plein de projets puis le peut-être
peut-être un peu ce que tout fait
maintenant parce que moi j'ai comme pas
fait la tournée des bars et une espèce
de trois quatre mois où est ce que j'ai
fait jusque là vous consultez un petit
peu et équipe j'ai checké qu'est ce
qu'il fallait faire un piège mais nous
doutons le vécu théâtre quand et ans en
période de meetings il rien qui rentre
en piste récente continue à vivre
planète en un moment donné où est ce qu
on se regardait pour laquelle on est on
est à côté
si on fait pas une si on trouve pas une
solution en
rapidement on est à côté complètement un
genre puis moitié georges frêche sortie
de rodez c'est pas comme si j'avais déjà
clairement d'études
j'avais des mines et une semaine j'avais
ma carte de crédit avec un peu quand
même
akon d'argent dessus lüthi sauf que jean
rapidement on sait que ma côté long feu
kerry fox a fait 4 morts dont les
sorties d'odéon n'a pas caché art sur
rien qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe
même phoque blanc comme de fait bloquer
un projet qui commence tranquillement
les toqués stressant que les meetings
c'est qui mais je sais pas je pense que
j'avais mais au moins vous étiez deux là
dedans ça c'est quand même bien vous
étiez
ça m'a sauvé la vie parce que cache
sortie je sais pas prêt pour ce jeu
n'est pas prêt pour le parc à neige fait
pas prêt pour que le monde des affaires
je n'arrêtais pas de dire aux gars dit
moi je suis ici je lis et sauf que je
veux des jeux veut disparaître quand
c'est fini parce que j'appréhendais ce
puits si je suis je n'ai pas sorti avec
jesse heiman prends mon pied j'aurais
pris mon mon instagram puis je l'avais
je leur ai juste drop et j'aurais rien
fait je vais pas essayer de grossir
j'aurais pas essayer de continuer à
entretenir ça parce que je n'ai juste
pas été capable de faire ce puis on est
comme sortis ensemble on en parlait ici
j'ai eu des moments jeudi break dans ce
jeu ciani aussi mais on était allé à
chaque fois on jamais ça nous a permis
de rester en selle et monsieur alexandre
ichthys épaules mais son centre
tout psg si ensemble sans reygadas mois
ensemble c'est un peu moins ku mais en
fait c'était quelque chose maintenant
certain danger mais moi j'avais pas mon
seul pendant presque trois semaines à un
mois j'ai pas eu 10 mg pas utiliser mon
après ou des sorties j'avais un seul les
poches des pouvoirs laisser faire à
manger
justement comme lui comme comme ph si je
voulais comme déconnecter un peu le
genre à laisser tomber mais à peine
retombée même le prochain os des lampes
le jeu mais je vais faire des plus en
direct cette année
oui c'était juste un coup de main à la
pâte en moi comme je me pointe et plus
avoir ma petite chronique est une faute
en atten fois par semaine est encore en
vacances chez qui c'est toujours un peu
dernière minute
oui mais c'est plus derrière mais ne
compensent le monde pense et c'est
vraiment bien travaillé d'avancé bien
travaillé mais des fois il faut qu'on
fasse ce pain on n'avait pas pensé à ce
point oui c'est du manque son tir comme
ce métier sans faute se répondent c'est
ici la réponse était oui je ne savais
pas si c'était un coup de dés dans ma
tête c'est ce que est ce que en faisant
au des plus en direct c'est bon pour moi
ou ça me rattache encore plus à aude et
là je me suis dit bon je pense que sa
caisse à ces questions s'il suffit
dessus la visibilité ou tant mieux parce
qu'elle soit noire avec la rue de la
visibilité mais est ce que je la veux
avec audi parce que je ma clientèle
c'est un petit peu s'est fait sentir à
l'aise nous et puis j'en vois prêtre
sait peut-être que peu de sa frappe au
but d'inciter je pense jouer
ben alors vraiment différents appareils
ou des plus sentir externe mêmes
animateurs
même s'il n'y avait rien à personne
[Musique]
ben moi pour moi ça va être un autre
expérience même pour sa maison gibert
djebel de commencer si je sais même pas
encore qu'est ce que je ferais comme
chronique vais y penser
baptisé pas choix de réagir aux
émissions aussi nous faut quand même que
j'écoute l'émission la tva ne pas
l'écouter gîte à vin même que moi je les
fait je n'ai jamais écouté
j'écoute pas l'intelligence ses
occupations surtout pas aux québécois en
même temps ouais mais j'écoute pas
beaucoup d'émissions québécois jugent
des fois de mon et flix mélodies d'accès
d'aol en fait je te dirais la majorité
du temps j'écoute des animés japonais
l'âge le pacs mais pas cailloux site et
à la pauvreté qui au delà des cours
d'eau bord non non non oui j'ai
récemment regarder surtout que
maintenant il ya une coupe que je
connais là dedans que je me dis ah je
vois que ce que le monde se disait qu'en
fait que ce qui me connaissaient
personnellement voyez j'en sais par
expérience que j'ai hâte de faire comme
devoir maintenant poésie que j'ai ce que
je connais bien fils que je connais bien
que catherine je connais pas beaucoup
mais je les devine que de fossoyeurs de
voir qu'est ce que je vais me dire - en
voir la personne que je connais la vraie
vie c'est un genre de voir le contraste
de trevi aux dévôts c'est ça correspond
bien à la personne que moi je connais
leur éviter ce qui sait que gère d'euros
ouais parce qu'en prépa le vent vraiment
non
regardez c'était quasiment comme si je
savais que c'était passé ni ouais ouais
aussi je me voyais j'analysais tout mais
comme j'analysais c'est comme si moi
j'analyse ma propre chanson d'un autre
oeil et une oreille en fait les 15 et
l'écouté c'est ce que j'ai fait j'en ben
voyons s'était pas même pas tous pas -
bamba porte de mon bord je pense que
c'était pas mal sur nous et peut-être la
relation djsi ph qui redoutent que
c'était un petit peu bizarre
skaff a faim c'est tout soit revenue sur
scène où il avait vécu
ouais c'était plus être la seule à faire
qu'est vraiment paru quand vous parliez
paul getty musique et son client comme
miss votre loge à chaque fois qu'ils
avaient l'occasion c'était comme si vous
êtes juste la musique cheesy puis nous
montrer s'embrasser alors question vous
avez des grosses discussions utilisés
nous nous parlons est ce que quand est
sorti puis et tout le succès des baies
groupe bigard scanner maroc et tunisie
à ce titre prend le nom de la scène tout
au long de la semaine jusqu'à temps que
je crois aux palourdes à radio était là
pour dans le calaisis
il y avait steve bégin à côté de moi
parce qu'on était là pour challenge ou
d'enfant puis avait il y avait paul
houde le alors d'abord celui ci pour
challenges eut foncé qui est bon
français le est aussi le seul fait de la
musique
alors quel est ton nom de quel est le
nom du duo le groupe
je sais que je fais le même temps même
temps par rapport à ce que j'ai fait un
audit je pense tu es le meilleur non
parce que ça à odéon n'est pas supposé
de faire de la promo d'une promotion de
quoi que ce soit comme une expression
mais je fais exprès
je pourrais le plaquer la raison la
gaudi c'était pour des gros budget avec
des albums des groupes et dj moi je vais
aller le plugin - ben là bas pour des
gros bugs tout le monde ces groupes sont
l'expression lp par ajout si ça a marché
moscou estime et jeté à l'eau et a
finalement le fouet qui on s'est
rencontrés pendant je suis dit salut mon
groupe de contact au pakistan quatre la
photo est sorti sur le juste mot 17
khimki premier qui est ma grand-mère a
monté ce stage perdre et ça je le vois
magnifier même pas un voyage 18 plein
d'eau de grande écoute c'est beau c'est
un bon gars et moi je tu arrives à ce
moment le monde j'ai donné ma caravane à
ma meilleure amie c'est quelque chose on
a sûrement vécu de se faire enfin c'est
un gros à main moi je m'y attendais pas
mais on dirait qu'ils ont le moi je les
centres simen pythie juste quand il
chéquier les commentaires sur facebook
checkez quand parler au monde les
dernières semaines c'est adamo adamo sa
ressortie milieu ça comme fait méritoire
deuxième semaine les jambes c'est faux
que j'ai quand même vécu jeté comme un
petit peu nombre de huit cents par
rapport à la finale parce que je
vouvoyais vous autant à 20 mois d'offre
les derniers les dernières semaines que
le jouer ma famille je voyais mes amis
puis on dirait que la photo est sorti
puis gelé comme gelé comme pas réalisé
pas le genre m'enrichis qu'en fait je
suis venu
thouars tout tu m'apportes marqué je
pense que mon groupe est même plus après
c'est juste descendu vers ma famille
puis on dirait que tu es toujours j'ai
comme peut réaliser ce qui venait de se
passer
puis après ça s'est apprécié à quelques
lieux qu'on en parlait la semaine passée
a précisé qu en fait de bon le genre
c'est quand même un gros prix le
comédien y participer mais par exemple
romain s'est manifestée à moto en avance
et se jeter une partie reculée au chu
d'angers avec le challenge toutefois
ouais ouais ouais d'ailleurs j'étais un
fan semaine tél enfin une semaine
c'est la première fois mais en fait mais
je sais j'en ai parlé beaucoup à la
baule métier leur tournée qui justement
mais ma copine je te parler on dirait
mon ex à ce moment là mais bon je peux
en parler vraiment choqué juste après la
foire comme si c'est un châtain que
maman rencontrée c'est par un film à
fond c'était comme la rencontre estimant
qu'une coupe de mj nouveau flacon maison
et ici c'est moi qui ai pris beaucoup de
temps parce que dans le fond je voulais
pas acheter des trucs parce que moi je
suis plein les yeux
je ne le cacherai pas je promets un bon
là dedans dit bien en plus que je savais
que l'alexandrie voulait vendre faire
que je t'ai qu'est ce que je fais ce que
je pense des immeubles faisant juste
12512 1500 complet quand tu arrives de
ces maisons est il que le chauffe-eau et
5000 pièces étaient comme des budgets
choisi là que je me disais je vais
attendre voir que ce qui se passe avec
la vente de la partie à l'import
alexandra parce que même année un point
s'était moqué de l'acheter parce que moi
je réponds oui même si je pouvais pas
faire c'est d'en marquer
finalement j'ai trouvé mon pote fait la
même que lui et monsieur chalet nous
devons lui fait la malle et alex se sont
alliés pour seul puits dans fonds aux
autres c'est juste que ce que de louer
des chalets mais là c'est leur premier
chalet qui achètent parfois 6,55 exacte
avec eux avec eux faites le maintenant
que deux autres ont acheté puis vous
savez au stock les pavillons des sims
était vraiment officiel qu'on l'avait
atteint 50 50
2 on a envoyé un design chez qui
j'allais acheter les meubles j'ai tout
donné je dis en toute autonomie la même
part dans le fonds va construire ont
soutenu ensemble pas kg ça a pris
beaucoup plus de temps ces musées je
pense qu'on a fait on a fait cette
étape-là s'est faite en juin juillet le
terme à plus de table ces huit à dix
semaines
les meubles il ya une coupe de glace la
dalle c'est fonctionnel mais manque
l'immeuble jean dégli on élit mate le
clip baby please be bad
mais c'est incroyable les gens trouvent
simplement philippe bête je te dirais
que c'est même pas moi qu'ils ouvrent ok
je vais arriver les gages à l'ailé les
arrêts de jeu puis ses falaises passé
historique
il fallait que je les ouvre du papier
instagram t'amène beaucoup c'est
vraiment ouvrir va donner des cadeaux
pas donner des cadeaux ou ses métiers
c'est un échange de serviable mais c'est
la publicité d'aujourd'hui mains de ces
feux qui change c'est bizarre on appelle
ça des influences le mot parce que dire
de nom parce que tu me sembles
qu'acheter jeunes là on appelle ça les
influence comme système que j'aime pas
le terme effluents soir je dirais plus
maintenant
taper un canapé je sais pas mais il
faudrait trouver un autre monde
mais le dos il est suivi pour quoi c'est
dans le fond c'est ça la réponse c'est
fou trouver réponse parce que vous dit
pas ce qu'il faut savoir que ce qu'on
fait à notre vie mais moi je crois
peut-être que je sais pas je sais pas si
ça te vas toi nous quinquin on s'est mis
à s'afficher plus vegan puis plus c'est
dans cet axe là on est un gros gros
comme un récit que la main on a ça
éclaire beaucoup nos abonnés on se
connecter sur instagram qui ont testé un
gros ménage dans le but qu'on combat
gagné encore quand même pas mal de
bonnes et puis si on se connecte et on
en gagne 45 abonnés mais en réalité on
avait gagné 15 c'est à dire qu'on en
perd 2,30 à chaque tranche de 45 mettons
la en effet qu il ya eu un gros ça s'est
recyclé beaucoup dans nos abonnés
jusqu'au moment où j'ai l'impression que
le monde qui nous suit maintenant puis
je le vois bien que je pose des
questions pendantes en sus pour les
bâtiments qui ne suivent pour le style
de vie qu'on appuie pas juste parce
qu'on a fait aux des tissages imagine
qu'ils aiment ou est-ce que ça devient
intéressant de faire de la pub en
guillemets c'est pas par d'un peu pour
des trucs des blanches mandaté blanche
mais d'un genre cela fait un peu puis
juge précise tout laisser souffler alors
un projet dangereux culture vraiment
mais moi ça me rendait malade et j'en ai
pas fait j'en ai juste parfaite
puis mettons une compagnie vegan une
compagnie le new balance de course à
pied parce que je m'entraîne pour un
marathon genre se pousse être présent
sur ça me dérange pas ça me fait plaisir
de parler de ce qui m'encourage dans mon
entraînement pour le marathon ont fait
qu'ovh course quand je vais en parler
sauf que justement de faire une coupe
d'affaires un peu random pour comme
arrondir les fins de mois s'agit de la
mesure d'efficacité de fer sur tu le
fais plus tu viens pour peser sur
publiés c'est comme si j'avais mieux
dire de la marque dans mes amis ma
famille même le jeu faut je fasse
attention parce que je sais moi je suis
toujours le gueux qui met ce parce que
l'aîné qui disent tous qu'ils veulent
qu'ils sont suivis pour ce les gens les
gens je le fais plus parce que j'ai
comme deux contrats que je fais passer
au big c africaine riche des faits peu
ses gros bug adamou j'utilise plus comme
je fais des conneries mais les conneries
peut plus calculer moins je sais ce que
ça passerait pas 140 personnes dans le
désordre ont rendu le sam dérange pas
trop mais toi mais en même temps je sais
pas assez actif pour vraiment réaliser
pikachu et et finir un petit peu aussi
la ta personnalité tu mets ton je prends
les ombres comme exemple il en est le
monde à suivre parce que c'est lisa
utilise en a fait vingt story par jour
et elle qui parle à son ciel qui sans
caler sur un peu puis le mont lâcher
pour ce qui est pour faire ça faut quand
même se fasse 20 story bat chaque deux
jours faut quand même su attirer et
conserver celle d'éducateur j'amène aux
jo je suis en couple c'est peut-être
temps de penser à ses rangs dit
naturelle naturelle c'est comme exemple
moi maintenant et avec ma blonde fait
quoi si je fait comme si c'est drôle de
l'alfa comme c'est un oui mais il est
trop tard
gypa pas assez pour le poste imogène
l'epo mais c'est pas ça rapport avec le
fait que justement avant rodez j'avais
jamais là-dessus la faire si tu mets ton
pour reprendre encore les en lisant ces
cas s'est rendu à 250 milles abonnés sur
moi ecti est parti de zéro comme moi
j'avais trois sorties sauf que tu y
étais des jeux films c'est quelque part
ça le transfert et le métier en même
temps ces vidéos youtube c'est un peu ça
aussi c'est la façon éparse 00 30 jours
lendemain sais même pas quoi faire
exciser sortie de g aucune connaissance
de et social ces zones occupées avec
rouge pascual et d'autre part à frire
les affaires louches qu'à maquiller
gueule tu es un dieu sur des aphasiques
hommes par la poste
déjà ça me fait pas comme commun c'est
que mon adresse c'est juste comme du
monde
on pourrait faire un échange service
pilots débuter ce que marc labrèche je
réalise le site du monde qui
m'approchent les kivus occupés nous a
fabriqué moi d'une valeur de ce rsa
j'ai plusieurs nouvelles mangin l'agent
de télé j'en avais pas avant
kiki mélanie leblanc qui je te salue
il ya aussi michael qui a sévi dans le
fond que ça c'est pour les gros becs ce
qu'ils s'intéressent à la tournée mais
qui fait le job incroyable qui n'avait
même pas mais on a en fait on est encore
indépendant on veut le rester si on veut
garder seulement parce que c'est un run
on paye nos affaires de notre poche
après se le cacher un autre
ça c'est cool puis il ya aussi social
network que ce c'est comme l' agence de
réseaux sociaux que autres une chanson
je n'ai aucune des petits des fois même
aux autres c'est dix fois il me voit
fabi si je la vois là là c'est gabriel
c'est à me regarder comme on subit comme
jusqu'à été découragé un individu
découragés c'est toi fax à ses collègues
faut pas que change cette sage content
qu'ils voient seulement
oui mais les maisons les influences ça
paraît qu'un sport est le cas depuis
tellement level de conduire c'est quoi
ça je pense que je le suis de toutes les
sphères peu importe laquelle
mais les gros becs c'est cette scission
on a fait l'album c'est quelqu'un qui
vit on a un photographe manille qui qui
nous demande c'est quoi la ligne
directrice de votre album je sais c'est
tellement grave comment qu'on sort du
cac 40 en automne que c'est quasiment
sûr l'avait fait un album rempli de 5
gouges ok mais ya pas de thèmes qui
reviennent pas vraiment bien servi un
peu défaut est la seule qui sorti
d'ailleurs qui
c'est la classe on a parlé jean ségalat
dhabi future
en fait ils plâtrier platinum le cefac
le cool justement est la dernière fois
que j écris je pense que j'écris mn
après un mois phare history month
histoire ils me font tellement à fond
bref mais moins avec l'album tiller
comme ray aucune ligne directe restée en
bons on ne tourne que si c'est
complètement stupide même tassart fait
un peu oublier les billets bien les gros
becs parce que jusque là le premier
album qui n'est pas un album qui partira
au des boniments de fait parce que je
savais que je partais pts les il faut
soit de quoi non mais en même temps
quand on ne sait pas maintenant
s'attaquer avec quelque chose entre 5 et
atteint qu'en face de quoi fin de la
partie les gros becs parce qu'on a fait
des vidéos quant à 20 h il y en avait
une coque était devenu comme virale cpo
virales comme aux states ce genre qu'ils
aillent on avait chacun non non ça solo
puis là on avait décidé comme crise on
n'arrêtait pas des gros big dan aux
affaires petit on appelle à deux crétins
ont trouvé ça on s'est dit on veut
garder ce petit groupe et si ça peut le
regretter un peu après le ca va montrer
qu'il a sa star elle a nivelé un peu les
choses gro big c'est pas juste du
niaisage 146e jean-claude agnese sont
calés que l'on avait décidé de face mais
pauvre et là on va se le dire c'est un
repos dû être assez pour pouvoir faire
la tournée qu'on a fait c'est des fois
j'ai connu d'autres artistes qui sortent
des affaires nouvelles que j'ai trouvé
que 46 à cause de la visibilité qu'on a
eu c'est km h 15 j'ai pas très
confortable des foules humaines ont fait
tourner ça n'a pas de sens les gosses
convient le pour tout ce qu'on a fait là
si on a fait des choses il ya des tonnes
dont l'egypte une nappe qincho année
on va en profiter pour le prochain album
jan voss
on va se forcer le bleu pour simple on
s'est vraiment on ne voulut faire autre
chose
il ya une énorme différence entre la
nouvelle donne politique d'avant c'est
un autre simple quand on a voulu petits
comme aux temps autant côté sont autant
que des enregistrements haute et mixage
côté beat déjà partants on ne nous beats
heures on n'avait même pas nous booster
ses débits 10 août ou qu'on veut qu'on
double des industries qui tourne partout
le système n'importe quoi là qui active
le déjà là aussi on a les listes m spitz
all mix albi dans le sont peut-être tout
seul bien c'est masterisé l'autre même
pas masteriser c'était une vraie joke
l'album du groupe big joe sacco savent
peut-être mais on s'attendait pas ça
devenait déjà gros avant même au déjà
plus gros que c'est exposer les aider
quand est peu connue table des 30-40
qu'est 50000 views directe quitte dit
steve jobs sait que la fête commence a
dit être une joke l'on pourrait
peut-être faire la queue pour vrai on y
pensait déjà à l'album d'eux le haut des
d'arriver là comme dans ma vie ne plus
jeter aux chiens star aux dj set
justement parce que moi je les y ai fait
un post sur facebook à 200 like 200 lac
t aujourd'hui je le ressens la green
team et bal taquin il ya eu jean huby
salle ait lâché comme christophe
inscrivent quatre fois je n'en mange ta
la dernière journée
si je m'attendais à rien après la photo
the les fêtes loin récemment rappelé et
moi je m'attendais pas à cela
têtu confiance était dessus est ce
qu'après tonton entraîné le temps d'être
un faux cul moi je mange je m'attends à
rien rien de rien mais je pense que
c'est ce qu'ils ont comme moi j'avais
bouclé confiant pour lui-même j'avais
dit mme auger les jets paris ouais c'est
tout si tu fais l'audition tu le fais
pour vrai et la petite force c'est
sauter prix tibhrine je te paraît 200
pièces même que tout est repris par un
leur nom même sera jamais pris un très
bel hôtel était pas content pourquoi ces
émissions des émissions de la musique tu
es content dans le stic l'iphone et oui
y'a pas un peu ça retirer aujourd'hui
que dans le temps aujourd'hui les
retombées même champ immense même oui
mais je pense que dans le temps aussi
qu'aucun le quai sont encore visibles et
les pauvres veulent pas ce spectacle
c'est juste les gagnants des autres
années le moins partagés
je m'étais sentie mal j'en avais
rencontré un gp c'est un groupe en c1
gagnant je sais pas trop soleil en à
fondre et après puis jean jacques roth
ouais ça arrête tout chanter mais
reconnaît pas
non c'est un autre de od mais je sais
pas si un gardien ou peu un gardien je
me suis une autre année mouais
non j'en ai je n'ai jamais jamais
écoutés mais c'est l'amendé fois ici y
penser je dis ce vraiment rien écouté
j'ai c'est comme la maison de l'amour la
première fois en vienne à limoges
capitaine nicklas fait jadis paulo mais
le monde québec le réalise pas même km
mamour serov mais justement we want to
be suitable hip hop trip hammam et
arrive un moment qui était bas qui est
trop forte et touffah l'extension parce
que si c'était pas je te fais pas que
deux fois
moi ma fille jessie au début on s'est
dit ah non c'est sûrement fait rien fait
rien il est seulement 26 a fait
tellement de fois que tellement de temps
que vos actes faits s'est pas répétée
comme la même entre temps d'aujourd'hui
les calmes sont le petit truc derrière
les camille guibert virginie qui regarde
seulement c'est tout bon c'était qui
jean guy qui ont dominé dans le voyez
stéphanie au québec le 14 mai que je
pensais même pas au monde qui s'est
juste gardé quasiment et h m en étudiant
non méthylé ils peuvent pratiquer ces 24
heures sur 24 fait que le mode de
gestion fait un jour faisant et guy est
ce que je pense qu'on pourrait avoir
buté devant le jardin la seconde après
non la preuve que c'est fort la libido
part et est prêt à vouloir facilement
devant tout le québec s'est fendu de la
mort ils ont même pas mon truc mais tant
mieux humaines parmi on estime m
1 oui ont montré mes potes panthéon
montrer j'ai été content avec noémie
c'était vraiment cool l'économiste est
vraiment cool socialiste tout est
maintenant de l'amour avec deux des plus
touchées les filles ou six mois -
officiellement pour le voyais mon perso
ce jeu si alex noah alex pillé nos
émissions shillelagh mais dans ma tête
j'étais tout seul chez moi puis de toute
beauté mais à les fraudeurs
moi j'étais je vais attendre que j'ai
fait une coupe d'autres peuples podcast
mickey j'ai fait j'ai fait je t'ai fait
un oui je n'ai pas tant avec pat a
troqué vidreres j'avais le temps d'une
patrouille bien c'est vraiment un film
c'est bon mais est ce que vous faites ce
montage où cette industrie c'est tout
street bagram mais on peut faire seul
james imany avait du cabotinage investi
jeudi de la marne
[Musique]
je me suis vu les tâches optimiste ou de
mort
c'était bank ça st george à mais c'est
là la journée voici les faits étaient
rendus dans nos chambres fait qu'alex
vient d'un mot il était gros budget si
je pense que même à dax elle l'a pas vu
je suis madame raymonde sully les
feuilles sont comme à côté en train
d'être détruit en garde robe blanche et
adamo motta graines que je sais pas
pourquoi mais a causé ph qui me l'a
demandé c'est comme un automatisme
il est formé à ce moment-là jesse aider
comme tournées varadero
pourquoi on est rendus de ça il ya du
monde qui me disent souvent qu'ils
aillent magnifique c'est que si tu
choisissais karim pour amener carrément
finale tibériade maison mais oui j'ai
même vu des mimes plutôt sérieusement
kim kim 10e puis même si j'y avais pas
pensé avant quelqu'un me le disent et ce
qu'ils leur expliquer c'est et dans ce
monde le le monde existe en fait non
c'est parce que dans ce monde le même
adamo c'était j'ai jamais vécu ça dans
votre système
je l'aimé mais dont elle fait partie
j'adore la dame au port en plus le ténor
et moi c'était comme moi s'il n'y avait
aucune chance que je t'ai banques sans
pour de l'argent mais même nom 500
mètres pièce c'était genre tu étais là
comme le monde
c'est dur à comprendre quand même c'est
quand même te cracher sur 500 mais le
piège c'est la preuve qu'ils étaient des
héros stratégie parce que ça aurait été
facile de quoi se décolle la réception
du public
c'était facile de baisser et adamo était
plus et me karine au niveau des
personnalités
j'ai eu des moments vraiment lourd comme
justement que la seule fois que
justement j comme alex prenne une
décision mais n'agit pas
j'ai paniqué pour moman qui me disait il
par les eaux calmes
ça paraissait que joue un personnage
fait you had à moi je les croisais à
l'hôtel dauphin pour la première fois
puis était la même personne tout le
temps à toutes les missions les gens
d'ailleurs
même si j'ai perdu un parent c'est la
plus chouette espace la personne vous
dit même si sans abri qui comme ceux que
nous parler leur langue en attendant
calice marocain qui nous parlait je me
rappelle mon année var la semaine sept
ou huit genres il savait que ça allait
ça va pas être possible
il y avait abandonné qu'on ait soit
exclue on était afghane fait acheminer
du m'excuse mais je me rends je m'en
aller plus loin que je peux même si
chaque semaine les jeux - jeu pour
savoir qui calait moi c'est là que ça
s'est joué vraiment c'est un truc ph au
final je me jessie joineau la dame était
vraiment puissant drake avec une
rivalité camion je veux gagner au moins
16 et peut-être la maison c'est sûr mais
je le savais pas de lunettes
ce tapis rouge il se choisit par les
filles
le jaraaf on est tous les geeks ont fait
choisir on est comme dan fayot league
les fillettes pendant trois mois 3
ça m'a aidé mano final
la salle est bondée je m'en foutais plus
pour minsk ont eu peu fou le sait
vraiment si on refaisait se mettant
demain à temps et on aurait pesé phone
ouais parce que si on a réuni des c'est
quoi la preuve on est dans cette
situation par rapport à la preuve je
pense que je pense je retournerais pas
encore la même personne ne sait encore
moins changé ma personnalité de tourner
mais je sais pas mais comme j'aime c'est
aussi pour voyager tout et total 1
jamaïque et la place des martyrs
ah ouais vous en tchèque mais place une
compétition natation barbade qui est un
10 km open noix de cajou bémol 10
kilowatts d'énergie ces cas mais ces
genres pour monsieur madame tout le
monde qui veut ça se fait qu'on a elop
qui accompagné d'une lettre de natation
qui nous ramène pas ça en bike et c'est
comme une natation qui nous et qui nous
pensions pour que j'aille là et puis je
serai juste d'aller passer en deux
semaines à bruz attend qu'ils abattent
sur des pubs ouais j'ai voyagé juste une
place à port louis costes m
aster d'un charisme c'est vraiment beau
c'est soit que les youyous l'ouragan
n'est pas aussi sexy qu'une coupe de
grèce notamment traqué on va et le fonds
arrive lake city mais dans ce test est
atlantiste avec tu sèches avec mon
ancien coloc bas le pied ça blanc depuis
j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs au voyage mais
en france par rapport à notre frère
serait pas pour ma fête ne tant qu'on ne
profiter puisque enfants du g7 ça fait
c'est comme en juillet fin juillet mois
ses débuts où chaque année comme presse
début où on fait notre fête ensemble
mais dont le voyage msss et pour moi
c'est encore une première et voyager
sans contexte faut pas rendre les
voyages pas céder à facchetti comme on
dit oui on n'avait pas droit de faire
tout ce qu'on voulait dans les voyages
parce que vous êtes tous des libertés
comme l'outil il nous faisait faire des
affaires que même si je n'ai jamais pu
me prenant à me payer ce deuxième vivent
ce même géré même pas penser gros c'est
impressionnant je regarde c'est avec des
si le voyage au laos m'étonne on aurait
probablement pendant qu'on pourrait
aller au laos puis fives un voyage plus
une scène qu'est ce qu'ils nous ont fait
vivre pour le laos
mais le voyage en tanzanie sur la maison
fort ou si jamais j'arrive sur ma vie
car si c'est hors de prix à moins que
deviennent millionnaires pour une raison
x des livres de recettes monga félibrée
c'est toi peut-être si ça se vend
vraiment bien mais un métier semaine
c'est
c'est les affaires de ma gueule oui c
foot au japon la crise jusqu'au bout
comme un autre tableau de bord la jument
faire quelque chose c'est quand même de
liberté [ __ ] quand même sur l'eau et
puis on ne mange du jeu crise on veut
manger dans les bons restos jeu devront
absolument rien à te plaît parce que
beaucoup des fois le si j'avais le goût
de pousser là je serai juste marcher à
bali en liberté je marchais à liberté à
bali même chose banale même listé leurs
rêves
je te jure ce que je faisais des fois
quand je vais me taire mon cannes dans
montcalm à québec
juste le saut en maintenant il rendu
9h30 l'été disjoncter je marchais 500
mah aide pourra les hôtes des jeux me
panier une eau perrier bigeard descendez
c'était comme de compte je faisais quand
même assez régulièrement juste pour
aller marcher dehors l'été à québec
quand on en profite et captait pas sorti
trop de la journée des fois je rêvais à
bali en rêvant se révèle je sais verte
et de sortir chez nous neuf d'aller au
depp
nous faisions des quelque chose avec mon
argent a pu revenir
des fois c'est peut-être la musique en
plus je me réveille à la liste arrivée
deux ou trois fois risquée mais j'ai
tellement envie de juste paquin marché
jusqu'à la rue juste le goût de sortir
le sait jamais tout seul tu fais jamais
comme puisque toi tu veux vraiment voir
tout un tout tout ce qui est juste et un
skate jour la suivre via change des
batteries et stylos des monnaies ça ça
devienne une routine que tu veux juste
je te dis pas de passer trois quatre
heures juste passer 5 minutes maximum
revenir juste pu voir la crise de
rizières trouvaient six belges est
arrivé
au début en capoter waouh une rizière
deuxième jour au nord isère 3m
journaliste faisait fuir les oiseaux les
locaux menaient qu'une casserole boum
était en faute dans un temps de la
mouche mais il fallait qu'ils retardent
les shootings parce qu'il y avait trop
de mots chance cette fois qu'il n'y
avait de la mouche en instillant
alexandria vais pas nier une canette de
moustiques mais il a aidé ce prix
partout maintenant toutes les mouches
est tombé à claques
l'agent un tapis de mouches mortes à
octobre et de la cuisine ou quinquas on
avait trouvé le serpentin à la salle de
bain j'avais chier recrutement ou la
marmotte morte il ya difficile on est
même un pas des caisses à savon c'est
mon poêle je commençais juste avant ta
première jamais rapporter jusqu'à
maintenant qu'ils manient fofana d'amour
je te plains les gens que tu connais qui
vont way est ce que tu avais donné des
conseils mettant ballon je leur ai même
pas parlé moi je lis je suis un matin
qui est ce que j'avais pas de sel
je viens de leur avoir mon cell savais
tu avais parlé à lee couture oui j'avais
parlé à lui on a fait un show comme dit
je pense que rimouski hung et monsieur
métro est un lève tôt la clinique où le
[Musique]
smartphone quelle magie dit quelque
chose que ph maudit parce que ph me dit
que la plus grande plus grande erreur
que fait à od s'arrêter de santé de ce
moment le com sont ces cas elle paie
partie j'arrêtais taipei par six
musiciens lyonnais n'est parti on demand
georges way le bonheur s'est arrêtée
nommé jésus mendez ija en train de
continuer genre à avoir même des bonnes
habitudes le parce que sinon tu agis ce
crash est de plus en plus moi ce que
j'ai dit le seul conseil que je donne et
c'est pense jamais que tu contrôles
quelques choix des projets arrête de
penser qu'un contrôle jo tu veux signer
quelqu'un ça se pourrait depuis jamais
le jour
j'en sors un contrôle sur bien fait
pense même pas que ça devrait bonne ma
bonne vue amwaj à manger mais pas mes
lunettes le maire parlait m'abonne ma
bonne vision de la chose très jeune j'ai
gamehope assez vite changer give up le
jour où j'ai vu your ride seule la plage
mais j'ai fait ce qui est ciblée sur toi
t'es qu'une fois que jusqu'à parler de
rejeter guerre pas sinon je les vies
humaines
il partait maquis du passé je l' ai vus
lundi entre le lundi avant deux jours
avant qui parti pis il était déjà en
train de taper des plans mais j'ai dit
est ce que tu fais là c'est vraiment le
genre de scénario on arrête tout de
suite parce que son tour face à toulon
labo pilot mènent une telle vie rime
d'infos la seule fois où j'ai été mis
dans une situation j'avais pas le choix
de prendre une décision par rapport à un
jeu de stratégie mais j'essaie de
prendre celle qui faisait chier un peu
tout le monde qui est d un peu tout le
monde parce que sinon je faisais
vraiment chier quelqu'un qui est des
deux autres où je faisais chier deux
personnes lors des dna qui risque de
jeter comme qui cette fois ci un peu
tout le monde s'en fout si tout le monde
sortait 124 en allemagne le problème
avec karim qui est resté jusqu'à fin
août puis midi venez nous voir pizza
huit mois passés imagine si je sais si
ses camarades hommes par leurs noms nagy
tôt jeudi obligé de chat de fa cup parce
qu'on veut pas en parler de rester dans
le jeu mais c'est parce qu'il savait
aussi quitté peut-être un petit peu
moins
quand même dernier on le savait tout le
savoir en ligne est vraiment gagner
vraiment sans doute parler de ta mère
qui était quittait pas d'armes avec
l'effectif à il était loin j'étais mieux
dit-on fils il mon nom mais j'exagère
mais il était loin là dedans parce que
ces mêmes
aujourd'hui j'y parlais t2 en fait la
fin de semaine passée c'était sa fête
puis on est allés où on a fêté ça va
être sympa ça fait monter les enchères
et de ma soeur puis j'essaie d'y
expliquer qu est ce que je faisais avec
instagram maintenant mais comprenez pas
il convenait pas que c'était si
j'essayais de donner différents exemples
comme si lui et influenceurs dans son
domaine
puis comprenait pas genre fait que le
comment je peux voir que ça a été
positif qui mettront qui s'était même
pas capable si t'es pas garde de savoir
qu'est ce que ça représente
parce que mon pari pour youtube ou
instagram peuvent pas facebook une
personne normale la personne qui n'est
pas à noter pas fait comment tu veux
faire comprendre que ça a valu la peine
au final [ __ ] impact c'est l'ancien
format jeunes impact en main je suis
comme ça une influence ont enfoncé fait
de la publicité mais ce port est un
espace qui est
fait de la pub parce que même moi je
veux faire la pub partant following
c'est lui qui est capable d'état c'est
intéressant pour following qui suit qui
fidèles picchi un donné à tout le monde
et qui la situation un peu c'est simple
ce un peu de l'admiration même le monde
tellement je vous suis pas média decaux
qui fait qu'ils demandent qu'à sache
réellement ce qu'est le monde du 7 au 9
août
si tu as aimé yéti aussi les infractions
sont extrêmement connue que moussa lève
copains tout le pour toi là tu n'a pas
de public cible bien le pas beaucoup
moins que je trouve intéressant pour
être très exposé aux méchants août et je
n'en mets tu suivais pas d'influencé
d'inflation ma vie avant de venir
exactement jamais devenir c'est comme si
j comme pas vraiment un choix de pommes
intéressés mais de haut - mais formé
savoir savoir pourquoi ni fessées
quelle joie quel genre de public cette
personne ne joue de façon qui font
l'histoire juste ça va même loin juste
dans la façon d'écrire des affaires de
toilette histoire pop tout le mouvement
pourrait si certains avaient déjà
l'expérience à danse était monté un
contact à 30 mille abonnés avant ou même
clientèle faisait en étant extrêmement
rush était activistes 3000 effective
poster des vidéos de d'abattoirs sur
instagram
ils le montrent qu'il a suivi ce
principalement des activistes qui
voulaient se motiver en ruine factice
c'est pas la même clientèle le fauga
fasse vraiment plus tard simon s'est
souvent hamdi
mbh cesser ce que je peux poster ce plus
je regarde où l'enfer
trente mille abonnés sur elop le titre
en mai personnes au québec sont
permanents mais même si genre
s'apparente ont failli demande une photo
de m me désabonne si vous vend du rêve
un peu vaine seppi 6 m autre situation
se maîtrise afin d'en face kraft monde
mais je pense que c'est seule espèce de
qui est difficile à acquérir
je pense que c'est le même pour tout le
monde peu importe le domaine dans lequel
peu importe la personne de gaudi mais je
pense que c'est le fait que c'est
vraiment arriver du jour au lendemain tu
sais pas si j'avais monté mon fantasme
quelques années en faisant tout le temps
de la marde comme j'aime pas en disant
des conneries des saletés jeudi les
affamés mais c'est mon genre l'essonne
invite tous les jours quand on croise te
mets le sur le 143 mail que j'ai c'est
sur ces du monde qui me suivent à cause
de défauts mais tf1 piketty membres le
dans le fond le nettoyage c'est comme
ceux qui ont monté les missions de rodez
les nuages qui en fait les enfants qui
ont coupé ce qu'ils ont mis de moins
c'est ce que je dois à peu près je
montre aussi un petit peu le même côté
de moi qu'il faut démontrer avec mon
compte
adamo avec le congo belge pesée de la
marque aux cités avec monde mettant
atterré le plus ça va aller ça se
mélange et des apparitions à thé lipton
le jeu avec des cheveux comme ces
nouveaux éléments
ils mèneront pas opel peut tout dire à
tenir encore moins moi qui suis moi j'ai
craint comme s'est mis d'accord parce
que je pense que c'est le moment où je
fais comme le step télé qui est
maintenant si je te dis pas que je
faisais de la négo ce qui est des
grossièretés
[Musique]
mais c'est là que la pauvre fou le thé
mes joueurs mais je vais quand même et
plus + moi maintenant
blanc dit quels sont les réseaux sociaux
je peux moi-même et en blanc dit que je
fais plus attention à ce que je dis mais
ne fais plus attention j'ai pas le choix
parce que pense que mon fort louis je
pense qu enfin en ayant cette attitude
lot
c'était un petit peu peinturés dans un
coin oui dès le début est ce que tu
penses que tu es ce que tu te mets
préférés dès le début sur la baisse
attendue des phares à qui vous savez
quoi vous avez un montage de moi mais ce
c'est moi suivez moi sur blessure n'ont
pas su ou voulu me laisser quand je suis
sorti je te quand même plus moi ouais je
faisais plus c'était pas mal et je sais
pas pourquoi c'est en revue un déclic
dans la tête j'ai commencé à trop penser
petit je pense que même en ce moment je
pense tous les dix ans tandis que le
monde ça les dérangeait ou pas pantoute
je sais pour ses débuts maintenant au
début je m'en foutais plus mais je
réalisais - 11 juillet c'est comme si au
début j'avais juste ça monte ça monte
tout un match comprenais pas trop
pourquoi pas contre une autre phase que
je faisais je me suis dit j'y ai cru que
ce serait pas correct sans plus j'ai
commencé mes remises en a mais remettre
en question un brin c'est là que j'ai le
gj comme je n'aurais pas dû le foot
londres est que maintenant plus capable
de revenir avec le tanking que j'avais
le même stade que j'avais parce qu'on
dirait que j'ai comme un peu perdu goût
j'ai moins envie de comme folle histoire
oui j'ai moins envie d'être c'était le
fun parce qu'il faut que tu calcules tu
fou de penser que ceux ci comme je suis
content injuste anges dans un dilemme en
ce moment au même genre est ce que
j'aime encore laisse complètement je
fais juste faire ce que j'aime tant je
pense ici là dessus je mens en ligne oui
moi pauvre et je pense que c'est la
bonne avenue à prendre à ce petit jeu-là
dire l'impact que ça aurait changé
maintenant peut être moins d'abonnés
dans la tête plus même si c'est les
poches en pétition jeu sera différent du
logement fois c'est si tout va la
défendre la dame souhaite toi même je
pense que c'est plus important c'est un
peu comme si je me demandais genre est
ce que j'ai fait au des six est pas
faite aux délais groupe et que ça
marcherait autant je les fais est trop
tard cependant cette question le fait
qu'ils sont à suivre
les cats mais agacé des caisses quel
monde veulent c'est qu'est-ce que le
monde veut le voir qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent entendre nguesso époux tu fais
ce que tu veux poursuivre ses cd fois je
me demande même si je devrais pas
maintenant je fais le pour montrer que
je peux le porter je te fais mon arrivée
papa le film est juste pas je fais le
post natale montrer mais je dis je vous
ai pas parlé parce qu'on dit que les
réseaux sociaux et ça aussi que je
trouve pas je sais c'est un peu d'un
trop parfait ces mêmes dérives mais tu
vois même moi je pense que c'est
exactement pour ceux qui ont une espèce
de son espèce d'effervescence autour
d'un conte que mal à nice par exemple
pascal alice qu'un café le pot al montre
disantes kaka fait le pauvre nom est la
batterie ou qu'un café le port allemand
on en parle
puis le monde suivent ces gens là dessus
puis je comprends ce que tu disais parce
que ça fait la même chose on a piqué sa
remontée la ménopause toy story 2 mois
puis jasick c1 allait fêter noël mais
c'est la grosse affaire n'est pas le
plus fonctionner ses métiers ses pilotes
ça monte ça monte ça ce temps là ça
commence à descendre une photo plus bas
d'europe
je vais me poser une photo qui est ce
qu'il faut faire si j'arrête dans proust
est donc là c'est le moi je me suis dit
'je crois qu'il va perdre parce c'est à
dire il faut sauf moi je vais arrêter
parce que au final ce que ce que moi
j'ai réalisé c'est que parce que je
faisais souvent maintenant qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui polluaient mon une photo
avec un commentaire genre extrêmement
déplacé je bloque à la personne j'ai
cédé à ben voyons donc pas personne
comment ta place je faisais longs mois
qui s'y met on the block 100 personnes
ces censures 130000 c'est quoi la
différence logique j'ai eu le même type
king me suis dit là j'ai j'ai cent
trente mille abonnés
si maintenant je me mets à redevenait ou
aita exactement - qui a posté les photos
que je veux posté en mousse de la terre
natale fois que j'en perds 10 mille
juste passer au tamis sa vie de toute
façon mais ne soit peut-être d'en gagner
éventuellement soit peut-être plus le
fun a su igman que les gars qui calcule
ses affaires mais c'était juste d'être
faite qu'aux iphones jargon chaîne
starwood
c'est juste une affaire aussi pour moi
par rapport à moi c'est très difficile
étant donné qu'il est ivre pas moi je
mets une blonde avait pas du tout les
réseaux sociaux factions pour moi c'est
parce que je suis trop trois quarts du
temps pas trop encore du temps mais
c'est jacques est beaucoup et j'ai dû au
moins un tiers de mon temps avec ma
blonde c'est celle que chez les enfants
atteints phonique et si je mettrai ma
blonde à ce que j'imagine juste le jour
où je pense une photo de ma blonde va
vivre foule était si c'est pour mon but
que savez vous à cause que je peux
utiliser ma blonde se veut être toi puis
avait parlé de la vie
c'est ce que j'aimerais que j'aimerais
que ma blonde à la embarque un peu sais
pas si je vais pas l'attaquer nous ils
sont comptés privé à la même page
facebook jeudi gm sonne même fois que je
la paie au final bien avec ma blonde
dati
mais c'est sûr que des fois je me dis
qu'à aller se serait tu ça serait cool
tic est un marqueur de sa fin de vie en
même temps c'est ce qui me garde un peu
sur les pieds sur terre je sais pas si
j'aime ce si j'aime pas ce que je pense
je prendrai un petit peu des deux
ce que j'aimerais c'est quand même un
premier mais bien plus c'est une fille
en partant avec ce soir à lille j'irai
moi je pense très instruits je donnerai
le new post fait frisquet el jérid
mettons g4 est entré du jour au
lendemain je m'en fous je donnerai mon
moment mon compte je n'ai pas fait mieux
qu'en ce moment je fais une connerie
rédigé en fait toute heure trois quarts
disent pas c'est moi qui ai pas les
réflexes comme on parlait de menton
j'allais juste poste réflexion ne jamais
jamais jamais jamais l'ifo joli bleu
quand je lis comme à ce poste j'ai pensé
bon dieu qui louche ce que je veux faire
quoi chevaux moi même je suis moi même
mais je suis moi même dans un
environnement que je suis un peu mal et
[Musique]
c'est ça époque sais pas quoi c'est
difficile mais je pense que c'est
peut-être aussi l'être nous on doit
aussi de notre époque quand même
ouais c'est mon métier du monde dans la
trachée quatre ans je ferais d'amour 30
gérard bertrand il ya du monde de la
trâche kiki on maîtrise bien c'est aussi
là dessus c'est juste que je pense que
nous ça faisait juste pas partie de
notre vie à vaincre sur karachi là
dedans ça faisait pas non plus de
parties de nos bus ne faisait pas partie
de nos objectifs nos intérêts non plus
deux mais ça change votre part et entre
27 et mettons tout 50 selon de 22 jours
29 22 ans j'ai l'impression que si une
autre femme
j'ai l'impression que tu as mangé
la technologie va tellement vite toutes
les générations et là j'ai l'impression
que c'est plus à coups de 10 heures ça
coûte 5 1 4 ans et plus et plus la fois
moins dans le tarn un pentium rejeté
comme en chine
un an après à peine cinq minutes le
chèque à mme hakima je pense que la
société va dans le même sens traqué ça
va tellement vite je schipman j'ai
défilé 12-13 un lucky qui se tapent
story l'incroyable un incarner doivent
aussi la gothique facebook facilement du
vote cliquer sur démarrer petit temps
vont chercher ton programme
c'est pour eux pour nous ce n'est pas
facile mais c'est le même principe mais
avec instagram des monstres comme sur ce
un son hip hop c'est quoi ce que je peux
pas faire une soirée pop
oui c'est super je sais pas si c'était
des conneries mais comment cette saga la
main avec ma blonde challenge commence à
faire des stéroïdes des enfants et puis
je t'amène si jamais un guide comment je
fais c'est des fois je rencontre aussi
des gens ça aussi des fois je me sens
mal si comme je rencontre des gens qui
essaient d'autres influences
hermétiquement j'en ai aucune idée s'est
je sais je sais pas ça veut je remarque
maintenant je le remarque que ça c'est
sûrement un influenceur par la façon qui
me répond que georgi pas comme dijon is
a us a voté comme comme le spread vie
comme si je te connaissais match comme
ce qui est ici c'est qu'ils ajoutaient
azote et influenceurs par la façon qu'a
réagi à mon genre de salut salut comme
n'importe qui que je connais pas ouais
mais le tg je le vois je le ressens
vraiment qui excite plus parler rendu
trop josé puis ça me fait aussi avec le
monde de la télé parce que j'écoute pas
comme c'est comme jouer au début c'est
j'écoute pas vraiment la télé québécoise
ça que souvent croiser des personnalités
vigie j'en ai aucune idée mais je sais
tu pas malsain c'est pas méchant c'est
juste je sais pas moi même
si je sais pas je sais pas chercher
pourquoi le juge mais il ya une fois
investi ce jusqu'à pas d'heure où je
pense tout bas et roumanie ce point tu
es bien d'amour bonne job où et quand
même une grosse personnalité petit comme
juste trop pour pour que moi j'ai un
beau cadeau juste et un mario pelchat
non je sais pas moi-même panis pour ça
c'est dire que c'est pas un peu plus
sexy mais je tâcherai de système et
c'est quand même cool le test parce que
mes cd afin que j'aurais jamais vécu en
dehors des tapis rouge de sa valeur
cools c'était fou même soleil j'avais
jamais vu si demain crise de vie dont je
m'en vais le voir gratuitement sur le
tapis rouge je prends des photos match
que je suis le psig oeil dans sa
caravane ne le tour me donne encore le
ché ché encore de même dans ma taille
petit au final ça change rien au final
on est les mêmes personnes reste c'est
ce que les gens je pense voit pas c'est
ce qu'écrit l'espèce d'effervescence
tout le monde le monde tourne pas autour
de nous autres c'est pas ça qui donne
comme impression à cause que tous les
fardeaux ring il ya eu des fois qu'ils
m'ont parlé des marchés dans un bar un
même à chicoutimi il y avait un groupe
ça c'est pas mon histoire à 17 ce qui
était souvent de moitié puis un gars qui
est allé le voir il devait y va on
chercha d'amour ne cède qu'un malaise
ils sont récupérés par un va chercher
les fous je parle
pourquoi je vais chercher ton service et
design en métropole il faut que je
présente ma soeur qui m'aident aussi
pour voir les dix n'ont pas ma soeur à
la 72 mille fans were je sais d offres
et admettez juge les contraintes
celui-ci comme
l'opposition et qui met dans sa tête
était consacrée aux lys change quoi
douze mille fois plus qu'au service
c'est ça que je trouve poches de ce
milieu si je me dis moi j'ai 30 ans on
est on est plus vieux peut-être on voit
on le voit que d'une autre façon pour le
vit pas de la même façon mais c'est les
jeunes je sais pas si à quel point c'est
bon c'est des fois des weasel trop à
voir ce ford mais ils veulent trop j'ai
l'impression que ton statut social leur
art ait semaine on est deux personnes
qui ont une valeur mène également des
toits comment ça mais tu as chief c'est
quand même que tout est séché flop tout
un plus gros chiffre bien plus petit
footing
excuse moi tu sens tellement ce côté là
je trouve ça vraiment déplorable parce
que comme on disait dans dawson et steve
venuti le monde pour passer le bon
message
mais quand que cette espèce de folie là
c'est une folie le au final c'est rendu
que gbagbo vie quelqu'un était au second
degré
imagine tout le monde qui se faisait
bouillir au secondaire qu'elle est
arrivée chez eux ou qu'ils allaient dans
leur sport il se faisait calcé appel
qu'à y arriver chez nous ils pouvaient
ils pouvaient faire ce qu'ils voulaient
le sourire tu nous laisses debout il met
ses 24 sur sept états du monde peuvent
bolide tout le temps bio secondaire le
cool ou la cour de l'école tu es comme
on sait que c'est lui sauf que y'a pas
un chiffre équivalent à l'exquise et
qu'elle s'est officiellement jean mathon
andré laurendeau l'ancien parrain le
plus cool d'andré laurendeau est bien
plus cool que le cool de mon cher parent
sérieux
ceci rend d'une guerre s est rendue
comme une raison d'être un ami ou de
peau est un outil nécessaire pour m
et je me dis que c'est moche je suppose
qu aux seconds à la crise ça fait
longtemps je vais ça fait autant
d'années que tout ce qu'on a c'est là où
je dirais plutôt sur la fac ci je ne
sais pas mais j'imagine que ça doit
avoir un impact quand ça lui ai dit
pleine je sais pas je sais pas quel
point mes enfants je sais pas si c'est
bon je sais pas si il ya une bonne
affaire avec les réseaux sociaux may et
que je sais pas à quel point c'est
mauvais aussi des équations pour le
bowling ses affaires étaient intimidés
des gens s'arrêtent est encore plus
facile mais plus tristes ou s'il est
parce que c'est quelqu'un de celui qui
reçoit à sa note était là jamais cette
loge pas c'est le seul côté kim gosse un
peu des réseaux sociaux parce que je
sais que ça se passe sur ce sport c'est
sûr je ne suis pas dans cinq ans imagine
si ç'avait s'est rendu le savez écouter
je serai quoi ça va je déchiffre tout le
talent un trou sociale aux gens qui les
emmènent les 4 laissant qui ont des
privilèges que les troupes les deux
mines selah sue klaus mann qui j'ai vu
un article passé même que genre en chine
il ya un système un peu comme ce qui
s'est passé c'est pas humain c'est ainsi
c'est qu'on perd un peu parce qu'ils ont
déposée parce que les principes que
qu'on a peut-être une valeur égale c'est
ce que je trouve pas acheter c'est
quasiment une sorte nouvelle sorte de
racisme genre que l'on en sort diplômé
ça me fait encore un petit peu chez pas
comment j'ai réussi je sais pas comment
prendre ce est ce que je le prends
positif puisque ce que j'essaie de faire
de quoi avec ce est ce que est ce que je
suis juste give up je suis dit la marque
bugatti directement la fin j'ai mon
projet que je sais pas si ça me tente
même lent
c'est la dante et j'aimerais ça allait
les écoles secondaires étaient justement
c'est de clarifier sur un peu un petit
de rendre ce plus humain mais en même
temps ce que je suis vraiment game lancé
dans cette croisade le ceja s'est luxé
gros le singe un gros dossier qu'il va
falloir que money quelqu'un c'est comme
si ce monde là et en parallèle au monde
des médias qui se côtoyaient pas encore
vraiment
puis c'est comme ça existe cbc les
jeunes pour les jeunes les lisanne
nadeau mm + b que ben des vedettes mendy
système québécois
sauf que personne n'a connu dans le
milieu des gens qui sont pas sur
instagram et youtube mais parions qu
unité c'est qu'ils mènent d'ailleurs je
m'attendais pas le cas tu vois mes temps
mais je prends la statistique ons et 6,7
millions au québec qui cueille 250000
personnes et qui suivent elle c'est une
percée une personne sur 28 du monde en
france que l'acier sur ce que mettons
que une personne sur trente mètres sur
49 incroyable ces foules non seulement
qui accueille nice mais qui à la suivre
s'il ya de plus que ceux dans le fond
parce que on n'entend pas parler de type
i se demande le sont pas encore
connectées les médias traditionnels
traditionnels puis les média 2.0 qui est
pas de dialogue encore en avoir un on
n'en parle pas encore si je pense mais
entre eux mais par rapport à parfois de
boeing
ouais j'ai fait une tournée avec le
groupe big star c'est qu'on était dans
le même wagon ramène les personnages de
malone de chrysler dans le fond ouais
bon les rames ncc d'enfance une tonne
pour avoir confiance les gens j'ai
confiance en moi c'est fois qu une combe
c'est drôle puis justement ça va être
salé le concept c par rapport au fait
que tout le long maintenant clip on voit
on veut être les tous les personnages on
était mais le truc confiance en nous
même si le monde nous regarde que moi je
plonge tout le monde est agréable de
martine aubry c'est comme un livre et
moi là dessus je juge parce que je
trouve ça très expérimenté n'a jamais
vécu je me suis jamais fait
le chef bobby mais j'ai déjà vu du monde
sfar bovine pige jusqu'à raciale ou de
quitter le mobile cette étude
littéralement pété dégâts mais toutes
étaient protégés les lis je me faisais
suspendre tout mais c'était quand même
pour des bonnes raisons qui les profs
mais savait que je faisais pas je t'ai
pas un méchant garçon je te dis
l'accueillir gentil mais je sais ce qui
m'attend médium saignant neutre
il finit pas
gatti bon c'est bon je regarde ma blonde
comme tu m'aimes à terme c'est la roxy à
terme un hatem lamouchi ta maison puis
ça fait dix minutes en sept jours pleut
ça prend quelqu'un qui rassure fait
qu'adam ou stengel séjour à côté en
plein centre ville les à-côtés son tee
shirt sa façade ouest et des bons c'est
bon c'est bon et j'ai soif les gars
ouais moi aussi
en fait ce soir
[Musique]
ok c'est six mois
podcast sur ce triste parce qu'ils ont
parlé d sera pas là mais
du fait notamment des succès limités
coûté des entrevues et les cuites seppi
qui lui allait pas bien qu'ils allaient
vraiment progrès rien un grand nom mais
vous allez enlever tout commence dans
ses sous-vêtements qui êtes à fond ça
transcende les réseaux sociaux les
shadoks ces semaines ci s'est comparé
dans tout le site big bang et sur les
réseaux sociaux mais autant ça peut être
bien autant ça fait vraiment néfaste
dans une vie de quelqu'un qui justement
lui que j'ai le même fuseau y avait des
commentaires
j'ai vu une coupe de commentaires pas si
je vais jeter à l'eau
gd gdg un bloc facile le trigger facile
ces vieilles sur mon commentaire passif
agressif bloqué mais non mais vient sur
mon poste challenge mes idées vient sur
mon post jo puis attaque toi moi place
d'attaquer ce que je dis non à la main
sur un bloc j'ai pas besoin de ce jeudi
m'imagine elles mêmes arguments tué
quelqu'un a peut-être vécu là tantôt à
son show
pas besoin de s p a besoin d'un bon
vieux personnes bref si j'écoutais les
entrevues de lui même pu lui parler de
ses pistes et qui pose les questions
puis il fait savoir le tiche des parents
et la déprime du puits les grues demande
puis avec tout le succès quelques tours
puis le film puis l'argent se sera pas
améliorée se dit c'est là que ça
commence et j'ai commencé à me sentir
quand ça a marché
ben si tu vois que genre c'est lui même
qui même qui aimait trop d'énergie temps
la dame d'importance 9 moi même quand
plus de familles plus aisées
responsabilité au final tout à plus de
capter plus de monde que tu écoutes +22
plus dépressifs ou plus chaque study
parce qu'il ya là qu'ils prennent au
premier diaries qui vont virer fou et
c'est pour ça que ces paquets scellés
parmi les moments les plus creux mettons
la en termes de mettons des semaines
creuses là que j'ai eu dans ma vie
il ya un haut pourcentage six semaines
là qu'ils ont eue au pourcentage des
moments où est ce que le chèque est est
ce que parce qu'en ce moment ça
fonctionne pas est ce que je fais juste
prendre piqueries c'est mon cas ce que
je prends ma moto puis je m'en vais
parce que j'ai subi ce ça arrivait pas à
28 je n'ai pas ce réflexe sincèrement
oui je voulais partir à moto mais je
n'ai pas envie tout pour j'ai fait
quelque chose mais sur pour vraiment
l'hymne des moments aussi ce depuis aude
et j'en ai eu beaucoup le team ngs
choquer j'en sait jamais mais c'est
encore mal il va inclus bloquer le music
il voulait que soient leur petit le sait
c'est un club à montréal
les fonds puis j'avais juste choc jour
même jeu distincts crise anxiété total
ça me tentait pas de revivre ce soir le
suspense a été de ma plus grosse crise
et veut j'ai capoté
pis si c'est comme si je n'avais jamais
vécu des affaires
c'est autant j'avais jamais vécu des
deux de pique de bonheur c'est juste
n'importe quoi autant voir ce que je vis
n'importe quoi non je rigole arnault
s'est enfoncé mises en situations bleus
faisait juste de la renommée avec
l'intonation l'astuce la situation que
tôt ou tard et primes dont ne tentons
pas tarnos et ce point il en chine chrd
dans ton salon mannequin paris petits
acquis mais
mais c'est clairement affecté c'est
l'équation est prêt et pas égales sinon
c'est pas céréales bonheur le tcmt
épices succès c'est que le succès des
pages ça dépend de ta vision du succès
dame est et s'il ya beaucoup trop de
monde dans ma tête que leur succès s'est
justement d'être influencé mais en même
temps je sais que tout est relatif de
faire un somme étant ce qu'elle est à
betriu fait puis par une compagnie jean
py devenir hugh jackman c est pareil le
devenir huge juste à relations avec ceux
utilisant des le disait justement qui
les habite riou à poses ton truc remet
son téléphone à son sac qu'elle regarde
plus ce genre de la la soirée tandis que
du monde qui sont même pas si actifs
qu'elle soit mais font ils font juste
clos les mines sur les stations rythme
chez qui je sais c'est une personne à g
qui tenait serment jean ribul et pas ton
téléphone ont décrit son puits qu'ils
sont même pas des personnalités
moi je saignais beaucoup en fait je
pense sur la majorité c'est seul sait ce
qu'ils sont immobiles et par leur seul
lasser ceux qui ne sont pas nos cinq
sens le plus à manipuler par les autres
c'est ce qu'évoque et jean fauque et par
la vidéo ou adamo t'ai dit merci
beaucoup mongueurs ya deux ans le
podcast prochaine fois que tu sois venir
mais vous raconter l'histoire des gi
puis de ces problèmes quand même de cul
devant la pression bien savoir si
beaucoup de vichy jean baucou